This is an image of,
of,
I would call it the patriarchy and it's
a lovely image.
It's God the father,
and he's assimilated to the sun because,
well,
because consciousness which is
associated with light is the builder of
culture and he rules over the walled
city and so he's the centering idea.
You might say that that unites a
culture.
That's another way of looking at it.
And he's got two hands.
I described the miss security and
tyranny altogether order and you know,
if you're in a university,
the u of t students complain about this
all the time.
There's 60,000
university students,
right?
They feel like numbers,
they feel ignored and no wonder because
their numbers and they are ignored.
It's no wonder they didn't feel that
way.
You know,
and there's huge classes of 1200 people
and they get lost and they think,
God,
that's a pretty evil structure.
And,
and uncaring.
It's like,
yeah,
that's exactly right.
But by the same token,
you know,
you get to purchase four years of
intellectual freedom and you have all
these people who could at least in
principle,
teach you something and you get an
identity out of the deal and you have
half a half a bit of sense here in the
library trying to read great things and
maybe you're not quite as dopey and
useless when you come out as you were
when you went in and so it takes with
one hand and gives with the other,
and you've got to understand that about
your position in relationship to
society.
It crushes you and molds you at the same
time.
It limits you and furthers your compute
capability at the same time,
and it's up to you to determine how to
establish a harmonious and productive
relationship with that because that's
one of the fundamental demands of life.
Now it sort of splits into these two
things.
That's the king who devours his son.
I love that picture and that's,
well,
that's a society that's become
tyrannical,
right?
I'm the son of the king is the thing
that regenerates the king,
the kings old and he's blind and he's
stupid and he's corrupt and he has a son
and the son is lively and awake and
alert and can see,
and if the father's not pathological,
then he tries to make the sun strong so
that the son can grow up and revitalize
the culture and if he's a tyrant,
well then he devours him and then he
gets old and corrupt and everything goes
into chaos.
And then there's the benevolent king
who's got that properly balanced and you
see in this picture he's got a globe but
his hand with the cross on top of it,
and that's means the same thing that
that other symbolic image did,
which is that the proper society
supports the suffering individual in his
or her attempts to transcend their
suffering and attain a proper ethical
perspective.
And then the son of the father is the
hero.
That's Hercules.
I really liked that picture.
So Hercules goes out into the darkness
and he's got this container and maybe
you can think of that container as a
cultural artifact.
You know,
because the culture protects you from
chaos and then the question is what are
you supposed to do with that protection?
And the answer is you're supposed to
wear the garb of the lion,
right?
That's the king of the beasts.
So that's supposed to be you and you're
supposed to go out there into the
darkest with your bloody eyes open so
you can discover what's in the darkness
and share with everyone else,
and he's got a club.
They're in his hands and the club was
covered with eyes.
Those are eyes not barbs.
And what that means is that you should
bloody well pay attention and that well,
the other element of that,
it's not expressed in that image that
you should also speak carefully,
pay attention,
and speak carefully,
and then you're the proper son of the
proper father and you can keep things
functioning and that makes you into
this.
Right?
So the city is always threatened.
It's always corrupt and threatened and
there's always something outside that's
going to take it down always.
And that's what's represented by the
Dragon.
That little twist and its tail is
something that represents infinity.
And the courageous individual goes out
of the damage city to confront the
dragon of chaos into gained something
valuable as a consequence,
and that's what human beings are
supposed to do.
That's our destiny.
That's our soul.
That's a better way of thinking about
it,
and some of that terrible dragon is just
the catastrophe and suffering of life
and our continual attempts to
transcendent,
but a tremendous amount of it is also
the malevolence and the evil that exists
in our own hearts and in society and
perhaps to some degree,
even in the world itself.
You're supposed to wake up and
strengthen yourself and stand up
properly and fortify yourself so that
you're a light that can shine in the
darkness and that's something that can
withstand malevolence and tragedy.
And what's your alternative?
You're going to let life crush you and
make you weak and make you resentful and
bitter and then murderous.
You'll take out your rage on everyone
you can and it'll only be limited by
your capacity to obtain power.
That's not a good thing.
And so it's this way,
or it's this way or a way that leads
directly to hell and we've certainly
seen that plenty of times in the last
hundred years and you'd think we might
have learned our lesson,
but it takes a lot for people to learn
and we're in danger of repeating exactly
the same mistakes again.
So you know,
it's one thing to complain about the
political polarization and it's another
thing to point fingers out.
The postmodernist send the Neo Marxists
even though they,
they roundly deserve it.
In my estimation.
It's another thing to try to figure out
what the proper alternative is.
And a proper alternative is not,
in my estimation,
to contribute to political polarization.
It's not good.
And it's not that the radical right is
the solution to the radical left.
It's just another catastrophe.
And the only solution that I've been
able to figure out,
and this is as a consequence of much
reading and much thinking,
is that it's up to the individuals in
our society is sort themselves out and
to strengthen themselves and to become
wise and alert and to shoulder the
responsibility of being.
And the demand,
the ethical demand to pushback
malevolence in their own hearts and in
their society.
And I also believe that,
you know,
it's very difficult for people to
respect themselves because they're weak
and vulnerable and pathetic and
malevolent.
And so it's no and they're not what they
could be and they know it.
And so it's no wonder that people don't
respect themselves.
And some of that's nature and some of
that's culture and some of it's
individual weakness.
But one of the things that I've learned
and it's about the only optimistic
thought I've ever come across is that if
you have enough courage to forthrightly
accept the fact that you're vulnerable
and malevolent and you're willing to do
something about it,
to overcome it,
you can develop enough respect for
yourself so that the terrible way of
being will not make you malevolent and
corrupt.
And I don't think that you have anything
better to aim for unless you want blood
in the streets in a pathetic life.
And so you might as well straighten up
and get your act together.
And maybe we've got some chance of
getting through this intermediary period
of chaos that we all face and make
something better out of it instead of
something worse.
So that's what I have to say about that.
So thank you.
Thank you.